you guys worked on Zootopia which was
two years ago and wreckit-ralph was six
years ago right
so how that's how did you guys turn this
around and what is essence I think a
little bit like two years how'd you
divide that up or what was the deal that
you're able we do it Clark just coming
out of a fog realized you know difficult
few years yeah I'm not used to seeing
you every two years I mean that's right
anyway well we started on this Ralph
breaks the internet in 2014 even
actually worked on it for about a year
before jumping on to Zootopia okay so
that was a little advance work yeah Phil
had had written a first draft of the
script okay then we we were on Zootopia
for about a little looking months maybe
and a half and then jump back into this
and took a look at the script and said
like oh we got to rewrite this process
we had a little distance so Phil where
did this did did you were you the
original story or where did this come
from
how did this well this version of rich
and ice and you know sequels aren't
exactly what you guys have been doing it
doesn't even know it's the first why did
this one make it through the creative
leadership team Overton I rich directed
the first one and I co-wrote the first
wreck-it Ralph and and we didn't
immediately think we were going to do a
sequel we thought it was all nicely
buttoned up and everything was just fine
and then when when we had the idea well
maybe maybe we want to spend a little
more time with these characters maybe a
router gets plugged in and Ralph goes
and messes up the internet somehow and
that was kind of a fun idea to us but
still wasn't there wasn't enough there
so it really was until we looked at the
very last line of the first movie which
is if that kid likes me how bad can I be
and started thinking that's sweet yet
highly dysfunctional you know he's still
defining himself based on how someone
else feels about him so his self-worth
is still a little bit wonky and and we'd
only met but now
be like 35 or 40 minutes ago so she had
a whole big story yet so that was sort
of the genesis of why do a sequel and
what's it going to be about what were
the things that you were specifically
looking for and how did you and and Phil
work together
what were the did you divide the work up
what or did you have certain things that
you were protecting that he was
protecting how did that work well it's
it's very collaborative I was working on
Moana still I was writing I Moana when
you guys were working out the first
story so I had come in and treatment
meetings and we had talked about things
and so when they were on suit I was
wrapping up a Moana and I came in right
after that when it was time to move into
the first the next draft the next big
table draft I mean Phil I go back and
forth with lots of things sometimes I'll
say I'll take this and you say I want to
take this but we still share it with
each other in terms of like the princess
scene that was something when I was
working on Milan I was thinking about a
lot what makes a princess and what kind
of princess does Moana need to be and I
was like what is it what are these kinds
and so that kind of stuck around with me
and then I also felt like vanellope
should be canon I mean that's the kind
of princess I am I'm like wearing my
hoodie's like this is it and so I was
like she should get to be in the parade
too she should have a coronation and
when we knew we wanted to do a Disney
meta scene poking fun of ourselves we
were like well if in Alleppey met all
the princesses that might break the
Internet Sara you're you know stand-up
comedy persona is very particularly not
at all I mean I think maybe it's your
your childhood persona be Porsche before
she grew up or something like that but
how do you channel that how do you go to
that and and I mean I think this is
because we're not seeing you
the actress part of you as opposed to
the comedian part of you is able to come
out more so do you enjoy playing with
that or do you do you feel that or is
that something that that is totally in
my head a limitation I feel what do you
feel that this allows you to be a little
bit more of character as opposed to
you're being seen as yourself oh yeah
yeah I mean I well I love
ellaby I missed her and and it's like
getting to play your inner child you
know and I feel so I feel such a kinship
with her you know down to the
comfortable clothes okay and so yeah I
just love I love being vanellope and it
you know she's like me but I go all the
way up in my voice whatever they just go
all the way up higher your hands get to
understand that you and John would
record together which is not really
typical so talk a little bit about what
that why that was important to the two
of you it was so great because it we got
to act I mean it's all acting and even
when the person isn't there like I
didn't get to record with Garland
but I recorded then with Pam or like you
know there were times I recorded with
Phil and there are also actors and they
bring so much to it and they brought
this to life you know so it there still
was a lot of that but with John we were
always together
and you know your acting is is reacting
to the person that you have this
dialogue with so it just was able to be
so organic and playful and we were
trying to make each other laugh and
we're trying to make each other feel and
cry and it was really lovely we always
booked like an extra hour at least
because we got we get really Gabby it
seems like this was put together at
really breakneck speed for an animated
film and it is also from looking at it
incredibly complex I mean the clearances
alone on this film must have given
several people a lot of long nights and
a lot of sleepless nights so what was
the secret to keeping all of this the
the incredible visual texture this going
well I think once we got excited about
the idea of the internet we knew that
the internet needed to feel big and
expansive and they needed to feel like a
world that you and I use every single
day so as a result we said we wanted to
use
real brands in the films but because of
fair use we didn't have to actually
approach the companies we could just put
them into the film that was a huge
relief from that standpoint if butch
like here yeah but we we really use our
visual development team and our art
director to kind of imagine what this
world could be I think that it's easy to
say let's go into the Internet that
seems like it's gonna be great ripe
world to do an animation but what is
that you have to start with nothing
there's no research trip you can take to
a country and use that as sort of your
visual language you've got to figure it
out and that they did an incredible job
of diving in deep and doing the research
to figure out how to bring the world to
life where was that line that you guys
have because you obviously did a lot of
things that I think and other times
might have been considered you know that
whole Disney Princess scene is loaded
with stuff and it's so host Erica and
people just lose it and of course a lot
of the kids are going oh there's my
favorite princess the adults are
cracking up you know so what was that
what was putting that together and and
what are the scenes that stayed on the
floor was a balancing act it was it was
like this this whole movie is filled
with like needles being threaded by mmm
bridge cable what is something I don't
know how we did it you know but it was
just um it's a balancing act it's like
our are we going too far with the with
the satire and not enough kind of nods
to the respect of the the princesses and
and we approached it like Phil would say
like this is like making fun of members
of your family you know I think the
pickets are done that way Pixar princess
jab was one of the favorites I think
it's so cool that Disney was game for
this because really the the movie to me
is like about looking inward for your
happiness and being mindful like you
know insecurity is his own is the bad
guy his own insecurities and and that is
in our lives our own foes are ourselves
we have met the enemy and they are us
there's that no logo cartoon but but
also those are just feelings and that's
all we're made of and it's okay to feel
insecure
and be riddled with those feelings but
as long as we can stop and be mindful of
it and wonder why is it that I'm feeling
this way and so to have on top of this
giant theme this scene with the
princesses where Disney itself is
looking inward you know and we see the
progress over this many years of from
like what we now see as a problematic
past to something so inclusive and so
modern and so reflective more of the
world is is such a beautiful microcosm
in the macrocosm that is the the whole
movie you know or something like that so
what do you as filmmakers do when you're
working with that big a collaborative
pool to minimize the insecurity virus
because I'm sure it's very easy to for
somebody to plant positive and negative
things so how do you how do you sift
through that great question pam-pam
[Laughter]
security credit then let someone else do
the work
ah you know I think one of the things it
really is help things Clark I'm going
serious on this one is a share the work
it's an incredible thing that we get to
experience every single day there's 900
people in one building in Burbank all
the entire movie gets made there every
aspect every frame is made in this one
building with the exception of where we
score it and our post mixing part of the
process and so every day somebody is
creating something new and whenever you
see something that inspires you it's
about sharing it with the team because
there are those moments as you're going
through it where people are wondering
how are we going to actually create this
world how are we going to get it done
what is ahead of them can be so huge but
those little kernels of seeing someone's
brilliant work says to them it's worth
it and we're gonna get there and it's
going to be a movie that they're going
to be proud of at the end of the day one
of the things these guys are so great at
is playing to the top of the respect of
the room they've respect everybody that
comes in and it makes them do not just
their best work but their best work
quickly to keep giving them great work
which is how we can work that fast and I
think it's easy too
get well there's a huge machine like at
our studio that's unlike any other and
it it's easy to forget that there are
people running that machine and when you
start to forget and when you start
thinking of it as a thing that like a
vehicle or a car or something that
you're running that's when things go bad
you I always have to remind myself like
these the machine is the people you know
and it's the relationships that we have
here that make the the product good you
know and so so just approaching it in a
humane way like Pam is saying and
remembering that this is 900 people at
the studio not a big giant machine you
know that that you're running every day
and running harder and harder